it's taken almost five years but one of
Europe's most controversial directives
the airline passenger name record or PNR
near the end of its long-haul through
Parliament we've created a directive
which I know is going to save lives
protect rights catch criminals or make
Europe a safer place for our citizens
PNR is about collecting basic passenger
details name gender age that sort of
thing to be used in the fight against
terrorism and serious crime like people
trafficking it can be kept for five
years but after six months is rendered
anonymous supporters say privacy
protection is solid Lupin air napus
honest robando civilians demas
indiscriminate loop enervate honestly
more selective Popo she owned a young
cadre par de Paseo extremo vigilant not
everyone agreed I'm las los demás
anubhav a song only difference here
enough geography shunga be torrid
sitecom East meter of a patient goons
esta carta una Anbar we have to confess
that external pressure has been huge the
debate is often being completely fact
free the lobby has been aggressive and
sometimes immoral and there's been many
at hominem attacks but it remains to be
seen whether we get the security that
everybody is talking about or whether
this is just fake security the mep
steering PNR says it has already proved
its value in the last five years things
have gone on to a totally different
level there have been a number of number
of people who have been detained from
their intentions to commit terrorist
acts in light of recent terrorist
attacks many mbps want PNR implemented
immediately
my tapes